[Music]
it's et's late-night roundup catching
you up on the best moments from Thursday
night mr. Dornan is mr. gray yeah yeah
shoot him
Malin Akerman remembers the time she
posed the nude with Jamie Dornan for
Abercrombie & Fitch you won't try
sometimes it's a huge success sometimes
it's a huge favor
Jessica Biel explains how she eats in
the shower while promoting her movie is
the book of love with Jimmy Fallon
who's the composer of the soundtrack um
some up-and-coming newcomer I remember
Oh Christie Metz defends her co-star
Chris Sullivan wearing a fat suit on
this is us he was the best man for the
job
yeah and people wear prosthetics all the
time they just happened this happens to
be weight and it's supposed to like uh
nose or chin also on watch what happens
live Adam Lambert addressed rumors he
was more than just friends with Sam
Smith no there's no romantic rumor but
we did ride a rickshaw in London from
one club to another wasted Wow like 3:00
in the morning so like there's a lot of
bonding
please welcome our next Bachelorette
Rachel Lindsay
[Music]
Jordan Peele weighs in on the first
black Bachelorette with Jimmy Kimmel you
know it's not gonna be populated with a
bunch of brothers you know 20 white
dudes and they're all gonna be saying
like hey you know I love Beyonce your
very close friend of yours Ben Affleck
is Batman will is Batman you've seen
both of those films I have who is your
favorite Batman well look I could
actually I have it on good authority
that will is actually Ben's favorite
Batman
Matt Damon reveals Ben Affleck favorite
Batman and how Ben's four-year-old son
Sam thinks the FedEx guy is actually the
Joker
whenever the FedEx guy come you know
it's dead dad jokey jokey jokey and so
but Ben literally is on a first-name
basis with this guy because he went out
the first day I was like yeah I'll give
you 20 bucks if like we pretend to fight
my kid thinks it's a joke and so he has
to send him away every day you know get
out of here joy